[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sack Yun
very excited to be talking about safe
artificial general intelligence that
benefits everyone
we have great Brockman joining us on the
show hello hey got beer thanks for
coming on really appreciate it
love your work you're the chief
technical officer and co-founder of open
AI which is doing incredible work in
artificial intelligence safety security
building artificial general intelligence
and previously at stripe for five years
Priya prior to that doing a lot of work
at Harvard and MIT building up the math
and computer science skills that you now
have today so this is a very pressing
time probably like the most pressing
time that we have is building out
passing the torch from the biological to
non-biological intelligence what does
your current take on the state of
humanity uh well so I guess the way that
I thought I think about is I don't I
don't think about it as there's a torch
to be passed here right that the purpose
of technology is to enhance human lives
right you think about the march of
progress even starting with like the
steam engine and all the wonderful
technologies we create over the past
hundred years think about the computer
you think about the internet like why do
we like these technologies right and I
think that when technology serves people
and enhances the human experience helps
us create a world of more plenty a more
equitable world it's good but it doesn't
always work out that way right you know
sometimes you look at more recent
technology and I think that we've
introduced new societal questions that
now just someone with an idea can
generate such wealth such value that you
end up with a very inequitable system
and so looking forward if you can
actually build smart systems you can
really build machines that can automate
you know human intellectual labor which
is the kind of thing we're talking about
when we say artificial general
intelligence
that all of those questions that we've
seen are just going to be amplified that
there's this potential for this huge
benefit right you think about like what
are the problems that humanity faces
that were just not really seeing
probably answers on on the horizon think
about health care you know cheap health
care for everyone that really works and
I think about human doctors today we're
addressing symptoms we can't go into
root cause analysis right there's no
human doctor who can go and look at your
genome and say that these are the
specific risks that you have and so you
know starting today at this age that you
should start eating these foods or
exercising in this way or should do
these preventative things there's no
human doctor who can see every single
health record of every patient across
the entire world and be able to
correlate all of these treatments with
outcomes right those kinds of questions
how are you supposed to solve that we're
just so many steps away right now we're
just stuck in this world of trying to
figure out how we can get our medical
records transfer between systems and so
I think that we have this huge
opportunity right we're on the cusp of
having technology that can really
enhance the human experience beyond
anything we've seen today and we're
excited about that yeah interesting so
when you when we think about it in this
big history perspective we've always
been developing technology that has
enhanced human life and this is another
one of those technological advancements
that's that were aiming to make as as
enhancing of human life as possible as
benevolent and benefitting as possible
to everyone instead of thinking about it
as a passing of a torch that's right
absolutely interesting okay okay
and then Suzanne how did how did you get
to this point of you know being here
five years now developing you've you've
you've went and given you've delivered
statements to congressional committees
on the importance of artificial
intelligence so they tell us about how
you became great Brockman that we see
today uh-huh
well I actually started out as a very
different Greg Brockman for a long time
growing up I thought I was going to be a
mathematician and I read these stories
of Galois and Gauss and then we're
operating on this 100 200 year time
horizon right that you know Galois was
this young mathematician he ended up
dying in a duel
21 I didn't want to emulate that part
but the part that I did want to emulate
is that almost out of nowhere he
developed Galois theory and it really
took another hundred years for
mathematicians that build up the
machinery where they really should have
been able to develop Galois theory and
so that was that was how I thought I was
like I want to do abstract mathematics
where it's never used in my lifetime if
anyone uses it it means I wasn't
thinking deeply enough I wasn't abstract
enough because I just loved the idea of
that deep impact the impact that's going
to last hundreds of years yes and really
that's going to set help set the future
for Humanity and that was kind of the
best way I could imagine to contribute
and after high school I took a year off
I was writing a chemistry textbook
because it happened to come up with some
very mathematical way of thinking about
chemistry that I wanted to immortalize
one of my friends said you're never
gonna get this thing published so I
learned to program to build a website
and to think about programming is that
you do a very similar process to
mathematics where you think hard about a
problem you write down an obscure forum
rather than a proof it's a program but
then some like anyone benefits from it
immediately right that that feedback
loop the idea that you could build this
castle in your mind and then something
anyone can live in that castle like that
for me was just like why didn't anyone
tell me about this before
and so this multi hundred year timeline
horizon it's an instant deployment to
billions of people absolutely it's such
a powerful thing it's such a powerful
thing I think we we still don't don't
really appreciate how it's how beautiful
that is and so at that point I said I'm
just gonna focus on building I want to
build software I want to become as good
at programming as I can and so I showed
up at Harvard I for for undergrad for
freshman year and I discovered the
Harvard Computer Society which was a
group of people who just want to build
services for the Harvard community and
got really involved in that sophomore
year something that was running the club
the two seniors who knew what they were
doing who had spent all freshman year
teaching us things they graduated and it
was I was the one who's supposed to
teach people things I was like I'm not
ready I'm just a sophomore I kept
looking down the street at MIT where
there are all these people who I wanted
to learn from and so I ended up
transferring I was there for another
year and throughout all this I was
working on on what the thing that I felt
was going to have the highest impact
which were startups and so I tried a
bunch of different things and never went
anywhere but from each one I learned
another thing not to do and I ended up
meeting some people working on this
payments company it was like do three
people at the time out in Palo Alto
when I met them I realized these are the
people that I want to work with right
these are the people I've been looking
for the whole time and so I was in the
middle of a semester you know I had this
whole path charted out for myself and I
said never mind I'm gonna drop out and
go work on this I don't think it would
succeed I expected that you know we work
in a per year and we fail and probably
back in school and I have to retake my
classes but I just knew that these were
the right people and so this what was it
about them that made them the right
people yeah you know for me it was just
we really clicked in a way that I think
is very rare right and I think that we
had very complementary skill sets but
also overlap in terms of the way that we
wanted to affect the world you know I
think one thing for me was I was 21 22
and I had this belief that as a 21 22
year old you can't really do real things
yet you have to be in school you have to
go to grad school come with something
cool they're trying to a startup if
that's the route you want to go but you
know 25 26 you can do stuff not yet
when you're when you're winning you were
my age and these people are my age and
they're already out here they'd already
liked you know starting to build a
company and you know I'd raised some you
know some seed round and I said one of
the two of us is wrong
one of the two buses has completely
wrong I just want to know who it is and
so in some ways that that questing to
kind of probe the different systems in
the world and see how can you have
impact and how can you have outside
leverage that was something that really
drove me yeah yeah that's so so
important to get to greater local
maximums of intelligence and and drive
to make new new systems that obsolete
old old ones that maximize our society's
potential and a great place to do that a
Silicon Valley and a great place to do
that is with people that are building
some
like stripe like something regarding you
know payment deployments like that's
that's a big ideas so then you guys
wrapped on that you wrapped on that big
idea stripe is still roaring stripe was
purchased right no no okay well
undefended okay
stripe okay stripe still independent and
then so then what was the transition
from stripe to open a I so for me I
think in that transition period where I
was going from thinking on this hundred
two hundred your timeframe of lay some
mathematical foundations and have impact
that way to you can actually build stuff
I discovered Turing's 1950 paper on the
Turing test and it's this wonderful
paper ever you have you read it I don't
read the begs that paper how do you
recommend you know and there's there's
really two big ideas in it one of which
everyone knows and the other I think
does not give that interest the one that
everyone knows the Turing test right the
idea of candy machine think turnings
like I don't know what that means so
instead I'm going to devise a concrete
test that seems you know just about as
good which is can a computer fool a
human into thinking that it's that it's
a is a human as well
then it thinks that's right right and so
it's like you know that thinking is not
really operational everyone it's a
different definition of it but this test
very concrete and if you can actually
sort of operate you can answer all the
questions and I can you know over over
subtext channel I try to teach this this
you know this other being calculus and
it learns calculus like sounds like
thinking right so that's the idea that
everyone's familiar with the idea that
people aren't and really captivated me
was turn said how are we going to pass
this how are you actually gonna build a
system that can pass my test
he said it's gonna be too hard to
program an answer so instead we're going
to have to learn an answer and he says
that you know imagine if you could build
a machine that learns just like a human
child that you know you could sort
program in whatever rules you know you
need to have that learning process and
then you got to grow up you got to
experience the world I'd have 20 years
of experience in an interesting
environment like this is a way that you
could actually get all of the crazy
things that are required to pass that
test into a system and for me what I
realized was that here was the key you
think about programming its limited by
what I the human programmer cannot
and like I have to understand the
process for how the domain works you
think about building a payment processor
right you have to understand all these
details about where you're gonna move
the money in you know like I you know
all the different error codes that come
back and you write those all out and
then you have an automated system that
executes it right but that the core
understanding of the process has to come
from a human but with learning ID the
human programmer can specify the goal
and the details as to how it actually
works
that's something the system can figure
out for itself and to some extent you
know the sounds abstract but we
experience it all the time right you
think about children right and how do
children learn and grow and the you know
as a teacher you don't get to program in
all the rules right you don't get to say
like here's how you have to think but
you can you can if you're if you're a
good teacher if you're doing a good job
you can help that child learn the skills
that they need and the right ways of
interacting with society and and you
know interacting with others and doing
good things for the world and so I think
that that idea is a really core powerful
one and has had both of the is that both
of the pieces those are the two pieces
so you're the storing task but the thing
that I think is under song is the way
we're gonna pass it is through learning
oh okay okay so then that the thinking
machine would need to learn in order to
pass that along the way that that's
right and so the idea of human
programmers we can only push our system
so far there's a limit to the problems
we're going to be able to solve we do
great things like don't get me wrong you
look at all the software systems around
us today it's pretty amazing
imagine describing that to someone in
1900 we're gonna have all that we have
the internet like no this is buildup of
thinking capacity that is really
important for machines and artificial
intelligences that's right and in a more
general the potentially the better
reasoning in a human society that is
also very general and complex yep and
exactly right and and and and in the way
that I would think about it just it to
add to that is that you can think about
the system's we can build today are very
brittle very narrow right we can you
know just the systems were all used to
you have a perfect computer and
if anything goes wrong it crashes and
you get a blue screen of death you know
we kind of hopefully move beyond blue
screen of death in particular but that
same idea of that there's just some
programmer who forgot to add some if
statement and now it's all broken it's
not really able to handle new
circumstances and so the way you can
think about is that the computer systems
we can build which really do benefit us
right that there are huge benefits from
these technologies we've already built
or just such a narrow slice of all the
computer programs that could be out
there and so the question is are there
new technologies that we can add that
increase the space of these beneficial
programs we can build and that's where I
think there's really time for the idea
of having the machine learn the process
yeah have the humans specify the goals
you know we should be in the driver's
seat but why should it be that I have to
spend all my time really looking through
the details of how all these these
little nitty-gritty a piece of the
system should work specifying the goals
and then having the thinking slowly
become better and better over time so
it's constantly running a iterations of
thinking until it gets closer and closer
to the goal and that's how its building
itself well and it may be it might be
instructive to look at I at today's AI
technology and how it works so if you
look at the history of the field I
starting in you know nineteen fifties is
kind of when the term yeah I was coined
and when people have really started to
set out on this on the journey of trying
to build machines that can you know be
be smart they can pass the Turing tests
they can they can automate intellectual
labor in some way and there are two big
camps there was the camp of you know
this is a little bit of a caricature but
let's say the symbolic systems camp
which was I'll try to write down the
rules right and they ended up building
the expert systems that there were you
know various other other other you know
approaches of just like having machines
that kind of search through lots of
things I try to encode some human
knowledge in there if like you want to
learn about language well let's encode
how parse trees work and then there was
the learning camp right and the learning
camp in some ways I ended up really
focusing on neural networks and neural
networks are this simple simple idea
that as time has gone on and as we've
gotten more computation
power have proven to scale much better
than any other technique and so you know
the first neuron that probably dates
back to 1947 before we even had
computers was a mathematical model of a
neuron and 1959 this this person named
Rosenblatt released the perceptron which
was really I you know it was the first
implemented neural network is a hardware
device in addition to a learning rule
and that it was able to learn some very
basic stuff and that in the New York
Times it was announced that I you know
that so the Navy funded this project and
they said that you know the Navy says
that one day perceptrons well-recognized
people will call out their names will
instantly translate speech between
languages and basically the you know the
other camp of AI people looked at this
and they said your machine can't do any
of those things it's over height this is
false you're misleading everyone and the
funny thing is you fast forward to today
and neural networks are doing all of
those things neural networks are the
cutting edge of artificial intelligence
technology that's right so the in the
history the recent history is that in
2012 so it's a neural nets we're kind of
this idea that existed in the 60s that
actually the Marvin Minsky and other
researchers were very big names on the
other side of the fence it's been a long
time we were trying to discredit that
approach they didn't believe in it they
thought look you've said you could do
all those things you can't do any of it
that you're you're kind of sucking all
the oxygen out of the room you're
getting all the funding we need to put
an end to it 1969 published a book that
actually did curtail research for about
the next 10 or 20 years so that was the
begin of the first AI winter fast
forward to the 80s that there's a mock
road ization of computer hardware cause
this resurgence of neural nets and
suddenly all these people are trying
these different things they developed a
better learning rule called back
propagation
they developed a lot of really awesome
things but once again the you know
somehow the that there ended up being a
winter where people got really excited
weren't able to make the progress that
they were hoping and so now you fast
forward another 20 years 30 years to
2012 and 2012 something really magical
happened so you know the did I to grad
students at University of Toronto so one
of them is my co-founder Ilya sutskever
the other is
and there professor geoff hinton were
able to train a neural network on two
GPUs which are just you know these gamer
cards so they literally developed so
that gamers can have really fast
graphics they're able to train deep
neural network to recognize images so it
was their cat or a dog in this image
better than anything else by a huge
margin right so you imagine what's been
going on is that for the past 40 years
all these computer vision researchers
have been trying to figure out how can I
recognize if there's a cat in this
picture and so they come up with all
these rules of like oh maybe there's
like if there's an edge here and if
there's a whisker and a whisker but oh
but maybe one of the whiskers okuu
didn't so you could try to to make all
those rules work and they built these
very brittle systems that just didn't
really work and then two grad students
with just you know like $2,000 worth of
hardware are able to blow all that out
of the water with a system it just
started out knowing nothing and you just
showed it examples and you just keep
showing the examples and something gets
really good at this task and so that was
2012
everyone's like whoa this is a wake-up
moment and this is supervised business
this is supervised learning with neural
networks there because there is a
decision of yes you identified correctly
or not that there's a cat that's right
yes and so the the data set that you
have has a bunch of labels and in fact
the big image big data set everyone uses
as use the benchmark is called image net
and when image that came out in 2010 it
was just view as intractable you know it
was like millions of images that were
you know poll for my google image search
and a bunch of other things and it's
like these pretty high resolution photos
and they have all fit a thousand
different possible things that are in
there it's you know all sorts of
varieties of dogs and cats and and I you
know like motorcycle and like thousand
different categories of things and so
all these computer vision researchers
using the traditional non neural net
based stuff we're like this thing is
totally impossible like we're gonna work
in this for the next ten hundred years
and two years later you know so I think
to 2010 is I think about when imagenet
I think they first starting the
competition that might be might be it's
like this like the often comes the years
I'm two years later this neural network
comes out from these two grad students
and they're able to just push so far
they move the state of the art on to
like you know I think it was maybe like
thirty percent of the time
there would be mistake with the old
stuff and then 15 percent of the time
there'd be no sake with the new stuff
and that gap is actually very very
secure because especially as you you
know you basically those the ones that
you don't make mistakes on are the easy
ones right into pretty difficult ones
yeah everyone's like alright we've got
another 20 years worth of research to go
from 15% to really solid in this data
set but actually what happened was that
every year from there there was this
exponential decrease and now we've we
surpassed a human level on this data set
probably 2015 2016 and now it's
basically this particular task is viewed
as obsolete it's it's solved right and
you know the funny thing is we haven't
we still have more to do but this data
set is totally saturated interesting so
there's a certain amount of human level
tasks that are already become obsolete
by artificial intelligence and so
there's a little asterisk - right and so
here's where things start to become very
subtle and you really have to look at
the details and I think one of the one
of the hard things about figuring out
what's really going on in AI today is
that simultaneously the details tell a
very interesting story but when you
really zoom out that the narrative looks
very different so when you really look
at the details you have not solved
computer vision yeah otherwise we would
have fantastic vehicles that could drive
themselves that's right that's right of
stuff that's exactly right and these
neural nets make mistakes that a human
child never would that is maybe miss
identifies a object as a human or
exactly right and just like you know you
think about like even a small child is
able to never make a mistake of thinking
that a human is a cheetah or something
right it just it just never happens and
so we have to solve that problem but at
the same time if you look at the
contrast as to where we were it's night
and day before we couldn't even we
didn't have a place to start and so I
think that that the if you zoom out that
the story again is a really is a really
telling one so you first we had computer
vision and basically everyone else in
and I looked at that and said cute trick
worked for your field my field way too
complex these neural nets that start out
with no knowledge and just learning the
sir never gonna work especially for
machine translation like can you imagine
for machine translation you think about
what you need to understand you to
understand language isn't syntax and
like all these things on and actually
turned out 2015 that I neural mats had
surpassed every other technique in
machine translation right and it was
like there was this this March of
computer vision speech recognition I and
a whole host of others and so this is
general this is generality right this is
if you have a label data set so you have
your inputs may be their images may be
there are sentences in in one language
and you have your outputs may be there
is there a cat in this image maybe it's
the same sentence in a different
language we now have the technology that
can learn to map one to the other yeah
that's that's massive okay so any any
any data set that that has to be
structured it can be unstructured so yes
so here's I'm so so so so that that
advanced that I refer to is that
supervised learning there it has to be
structured and that the thing that
people have been saying is that well if
you look at what data is out there
there's huge amounts of unstructured
data on the Internet huge huge amounts
but we can't use it for anything yeah
the only data that's useful for these
systems is labelled data is a labeled
data that's right okay
okay and that allowed me they'll be very
interesting to figure out how to train
our first hotel just to maybe label data
yeah that's interesting
yep so okay so now you so basically with
any right now we're trying to make it so
that with any inputted structured data
and a goal that in mind we can get
outputs through a neural network yep and
so how did you and Ilya go like let's
you know start open AI let's have this
charter yep as well let's be you know
very ethical heart centric let's really
be thinking about the Sun of benefiting
everyone around the
level yep yeah exactly so when I was so
in 20 2015 is kind of when I felt like
I'd gotten striped into a very good
place and I could really start to think
about how can I have the kind of broad
impact I that I want you know that I
think within stripe pretty amazing you
know today it's a twenty billion dollar
company and I could be contribute to
that but I think what I really like to
do is try to find problems they think
will not work will not play out in the
right way without my involvement where I
can really try to steer them from you
know one place to another and a I had
always been the thing that I felt was
the most important problem it was just a
question of when and you know after
three years 2012 is when Ilya had that
had that breakthrough and three years
later is when we were starting to think
about this we actually had this dinner
with I with Sam Altman and I and you
know I Moscone and others and the you
know I think the question there was
really is it too late to start a company
trying to make AI play out rather than
in a negative way in a positive way is
this something you can actually do from
scratch and the conclusion from the
dinner was it's not obviously impossible
but you're competing against the top
talent at Google and in China this is
very very tough stuff Apple or Facebook
Microsoft they'd still Amazon's just and
they can pay two hundred fifty five
hundred of millions of dollars a year
for these positions so how does one come
up into the into the rankings these were
the questions that we had to ask right
and really you know I think that AI
development it's not like a you know
normal science in some ways you almost
think of as as very underfunded and very
kind of backwater right it's like neural
nets in fact we're this for a very long
time the only reason do we have what we
have today is because this Canadian
moonshot organization was willing to
fund a couple of labs to go and work on
this stuff no one else was willing to do
it and today it's very different as you
said that lots of corporate labs are
involved and that there's there's a
large number of people who are working
in this field and so to have a
differential impact it's pretty not
obvious but you know we felt that that
this technology is just so important
right that it's you know what I
described you
supervised learning but if you can
really make unsupervised learning work
right you can really learn from all the
data around us yeah like that's only
unlocks a whole host of problems yeah if
you can really build an AGI if you can
really build machines that can automate
you know meaningful amounts are all of
human intellectual labor it's gonna
affect the world more than any
technology we've seen and so if you
believe that that might be possible it's
really hard to sit by idly yeah you want
to dedicate your life to it that's right
yeah and so you know kind of they became
the question of tactics right and it's
like we have a mission right that we
knew is important do we want to make
sure that Adi benefits everyone that the
world that we deliver you know we the
sense of humanity not the sense of any
of us as individuals to the next
generation to the post eight AGI
generation is one that is equitable that
is a better world than the one that
we're in today and I think that I think
it's very Chiva below I think that AGI
can be the most beneficial thing ever I
think that again the amazing
applications and how many people were
saying oh well be weary about planes or
be weary about antibiotics or be weary
about all of these advancements and so
it's it's equally as important to you
know push through the adversities
because it does end up catalyzing a lot
of reduction of suffering and increase
of health and that's right and I think
it's I think it's really important to be
realistic right if you're developing and
transformative technology you've got to
think about the way to go wrong and you
got to figure out the ways and go right
and then your job becomes trying to sift
those out and trying to figure out what
path do we take that minimizes these
downsides maximize the outsides yeah
yeah ok so then how do you figure out
how to minimize downsize maximize
upsides you know you made the the
Charter and the the Charter is a would
you say kind of like a like an ethos of
open AI that's right yeah and so it took
us it took us some time you know we
started out with a team that the you
know I'd done all the recruiting for
that and we brought together team about
10 people to start which is a really
weird thing to do as a
company right normally just you and a
co-founder and you got some time to
build product and some users but here we
need the critical mass of these of the
of these people to push forward AI
technology and so we spent about two
years really trying to figure out how do
we want to operate what is our strategy
what is our path to actually making the
future B be better than it would be
without us and the opening our Charter
is a lot of ways and embodiment of that
thinking and so there's four sections
it's very short you know it's on our
website anyone anyone can read it and I
think that there's a few points that are
that are pretty not obvious you know
that that the first one is that the core
mission of open AI is to ensure that a
GI benefits everyone and that you know
we in terms of how do you actually
implement that we can talk about that in
a bit
but I think it's just like a geyser is
going to be so transformative and it's
going to be so impactful that it
shouldn't be something that's 100x more
concentrating of wealth than anything
we've seen before that was a next 10,000
acts whatever the numbers going to be
it creates a lot of instability and
civilizations if it does that's not a
good world I don't want to live in that
world yeah doesn't matter which position
I said it yeah I don't think that's a
world that's good yeah
there's a lot of beautiful creativity in
people's minds that can be unleashed
that we would love to see unleash that's
right yeah that's right yep and so
there's a second point which is as we
talk about safety and security and
what's it going to take to get to that
good world well one thing we're very
concerned about is first of all people
not investing in safety research and the
more that there is an arms race to get
to the end you have a bunch of different
companies or countries or you know other
actors that are trying to build a
transformative technology you know
what's the first thing that's gonna go
out the window the safety exactly and so
we actually built into our charter a
pretty weird provision provision which
is that if someone else is pretty close
to succeeding at building AGI and their
their value line so they kind of want
the same thing that we do well we'll
stop competing with them it will
actually help them deliver on that
because the core like one thing that's
that I think is really important about
our mission is that we don't actually
have to meet the primary actors yeah we
don't have to be the
to make a GI benefit everyone for a DI
to benefit everyone yeah and that's
something I think really sets us apart
from other structures from other
companies yeah well every company is
trying to figure out how to how to
maximize their vision but they don't
think most often about it like if
another company is doing that same
vision and they're doing a potentially
better we can maybe merge with them and
help them yep yeah that's yeah and and
so and so one thing one thing that yeah
it's it's it's a it's a pretty non
typical thing yeah yeah yes
okay so then there's that there's that
safety component of course and then
there's there's fourth as well
all right that's right so well so we
have we have I you know I think I think
it might not be too important to break
out all the vehicle was that the fact
that you have technical professionals
that's writing it as well yes yeah and
this is the core strategy right the core
strategy for opening eye is to push
forward a eye development on that
exponential until we successfully build
safe AGI which is you know there's
really three components that go into
that yeah there's a technical piece of
how do you make this technology work and
that's hard and how do you actually like
figure out how to build a general
intelligence yes this is this is this is
this is the hard problem right and so
for us a lot of what we do is we have a
number of different teams that work
across different domains and it's some
extent the actual problems we work on
are secondary because what we try to do
for any problem is we're trying to
develop general-purpose technologies
that can solve a problem that no one's
been able to solve before but are
applicable across different domains I
have a question yes if if if your
intelligence that you're building can
maybe switch between intelligent tasks
that are considered narrow intelligence
would you consider that a step towards a
more general intelligence if it's able
to do two or more narrow I think I think
this is a step and I think that there's
there's this core technical problem
called transfer learning that people
haven't quite figured out yet which is
how can you use knowledge from one task
or domain in a new
humans are great at this yeah right I
read a book on Paris I go to Paris I'm
like I'm better at Paris related tasks
right RA eyes don't do anything like
that right now but we're actually
starting to see with some of the the
models that we've been working on
recently we're starting to see Inklings
of this so one example is this model
called GPT - which is a model that was
trained on internet data to just predict
the next word in text so you show it the
beginning of some snippet of text you
say what's the next word it just plays
that game gets really good at that at
that task and then it's like an Engram
No so well so it's an Engram for a very
large value of n yeah right so that the
context here are thousands of words and
so it turns out this model is able to
first of all you can ask it to generate
text for you right because you just show
us some snippet and then you say what
word should come next year what word for
come next year right you keep feeding
its output back you to itself so it's
able to write text and the text that it
write it ends up being coherent
paragraphs coherent pages on any topic
you want yeah right you can literally
you know we have this example that I
think was very visceral where we prompt
it to basically you know say we say
recycling is good for the world no you
cannot be more wrong and then let the AI
complete it from there and they erase
it's very convincing essay on why
recycle he's actually not that good this
was very interesting yeah and also one
of the things that when I read that that
came to my mind was that maybe it could
potentially be that the ideas that we're
not thinking about it from a first
principles perspective like you should
think about it from a first principals
perspective of them it's the way that
you transfer goods and packages should
not even have a component that goes into
a recycling in the way that's right yeah
I mean it generates very good discourse
right you know now when I see recycling
again I'm like why are we generating all
this waste in the first place yeah yeah
and the thing that's amazing about this
model is that an instance of transfer it
used this knowledge from this task of
predict the next word and it can
suddenly apply it to a story it's a
story to an essay to a debate to and you
know that here's where things get a
little bit unfortunate to generating
fake news
to examine the abusive content and so
this was the first model where we
explicitly said we're not sure that this
should be released yeah yeah so so now
the okay this is a this important point
there's there's periods of research and
development that occur at companies when
they realize that like okay we may have
invested lots of time and effort into
something but we can see that there is
potentially more malevolence I could
come out of this than benevolence so
what we need to do is we need to how do
we package that in a you know in a way
that prevents other people from
leveraging it to make bad acting
decisions on the planet that's right and
so and so and so the thing with GPT too
is it's borderline when we announce ed
this it was very controversial there
were a bunch of people who said it was
so obvious you should have just released
it there's much people said it's so
obvious you should not have released it
which you know given the fact that there
are skew camps I think definitionally
it's correct to be a little bit hesitant
and to wait a little bit and to make
sure you're doing the right thing
because taking action that yeah you know
might be negative it's kind of hard to
rollback
yeah and so I think that where we are
with with AI today and and this is this
is one part of our Charter as well is
saying that today we publish most things
we do but in the future we're gonna have
to decrease that due to safety and
security concerns and this was one great
example of that and you know if you look
at the security community in computer
security for like hacking into systems
yeah it took them a long time maybe
there's like a ten year period maybe
longer to really figure out a process
for responsible disclosure right so
you're familiar with responsible
disclosure in security yeah so it's a
really interesting concept of let's say
that you're you're a hacker you're not
trying to do anything malicious you're
just kinda playing around with things
and you find it a security vulnerability
and a website what do you do
what do you call you email them right so
poor so you so you guess you know them
and let's say that they ignore you they
don't fix it what did you know
do we want to do we want to use the only
you know 30,000 days we have to live to
continuously invest days of time into
trying to help them with exactly this is
a question so you know maybe one
reasonable thing to do is just to
announce this exploit publicly right if
you just say here's this thing they're
going to fix it yeah okay so where is
this going is that is if there's real
questions in the security community
about how do you when you have something
that's kind of malicious you don't learn
bad things to happen you want it to be
fixed but it's not being fixed it's not
being addressed no one's helping how do
you have a process where you do the
right thing and that the the what the
community converged on is this idea of
responsible disclosure which is you know
the company if you don't get a response
if they're you know bad about in various
ways then there's a time there's some
time window at which you could then go
public and this actually is accept it
you do that company gets upset at you
the whole community will say nope you
did the right thing right this is this
is this is the acceptable standard and I
think that developing community
standards like that you know yeah I we
haven't done it right the thing I just
described for security took us a decade
to do it it's not obvious at all for AI
we're developing these systems very very
quickly and so does that also expose it
to malevolent actors online so yeah
that's right and you got to be careful
but you know if you don't if you don't
announce it I'm lovin actors are gonna
find it anyway anyway and it's never
gonna be a fixed interesting so you hope
that maybe the public can push an action
faster that's right and just time and
time again this has turned out to be
true interesting and then this seems
like a pressing aspect of AI safety and
security when people discover these
issues and you want to have a convention
in place before you build the model that
you're sure if it gets released is going
to be harmful yeah
now you know okay
when we're kind of hinting at this
earlier I want to see if we can maybe
understand this from from a set from a
more technical perspective from you that
this and whatever you can teach us like
whatever whatever you guys are
comfortable with teaching about this
process but so what does what does what
happens when you start you know you were
talking about this issue with transfer
with like transferring intelligence from
a narrow tasks to another narrow tasks
but then you realize that you guys could
write out where you could write a whole
story and so so you you sort of you're
starting to play around with creating an
artificial general intelligence what
what I've been some of these these these
wide Awakening moments from you of like
really good steps to take to continue
moving that process forward faster yep
well so so so so again in how we
structure ourselves so we we have a
number of different teams we have a one
of the teams that I that I is to build
bots for the very popular video game
dota 2 yeah you guys are competing
that's right it's the world champion
that's right in what is considered to be
one of the hardest games to balance
strategy teamwork resource management
yep when your gamer you really get these
things about how difficult this for an
ornithologist to be able to beat them
that's right yes yeah and famously no
one can program in AI for these games
until that's right so you know we have a
system that has a learned how to play
and the way that it learns is that it
doesn't know anything about the game
when it starts and you know human will
sees the game as a bunch of pixels right
you have this image and you have all
this knowledge about like you know
you've not looked about from our
ancestral environments about like
animals and you know various design
things you know that like that there are
these heroes that are running around you
know that like getting you know if you
if you kind of hurt your opponents
that's good you know that there's
there's all sorts of things like that
they say yeah I starts out knowing
nothing and that it sees the world as
just a big list of 20,000 numbers that's
all it sees it just sees 20,000 numbers
not a supervised model this is a
reinforcement that's right so so I think
that yeah so so you know supervised
learning I think then kind of bleeds
into reinforcement learning and
reinforcement learning you still have a
label but the label is you took a bunch
of actions and then you've got a point I
got to figure out what did I do to get
that point what did I do that really did
I really deserve that point for and in
the case of dota that you we we kind of
you know one thing that we do is we put
in some knowledge about you should get a
point when you know you successfully you
know if you unit when you you know go
and you get this kind of item you know
that there's there some level of rewards
which you know kind of provides some
high-level structure to what's happening
but we don't tell the agent what it's
supposed to do and the way that it
learns what to do is through a very
powerful idea called self play yeah yeah
this is crazy and it can play against
itself at millions and millions of times
that's right and create as it as it does
it can it was you know iterate on its oh
like why don't we have this version play
against it's just this is yeah that's
right and so you imagine if you play
against a perfect copy of yourself it's
actually the best thing for learning
right yeah you try something new that
you know you've never done before
it'd be like imagine if Alan could sit
across from Alan and Alan would be
literally challenging me to become a
better interviewer exactly in all the
different aspects of how to become a
better interviewer that's all the time
and I was literally sitting here 24/7
running this process yes yes it's it's
exactly that and so it's a really
powerful idea it builds these were these
really amazing systems and now you know
that the product that we built like it
the work the end result of this research
of this two-year development phase of
you know developing the algorithm is
counting them up and all those things
he's a general-purpose system which we
then took and applied to a different
problem in robotics and so that we have
this physical robot hand which no one
can program no one can do the
old-fashioned like write down all the
rules like these hands have existed for
20 years
when's the last time you saw a robot
hand operation
intuitive search cool but that's not
even I don't know that's exactly right
even a hand right that's right and so
it's just no one can use these but we
took this system that was developed for
a video game and that we successfully
applied it to the robot hand to
manipulate a block that that went
through a process of reinforcement its
reinforcement learning to know how to
have a strong dexterity exactly it comes
to gripping something and it develops
these grasps that you know there's this
whole taxonomy of grasps out there and
the the it developed these graphs that
are very recognizable it's got the pinch
grasps got a variety of other ones and
that's all learned totally from scratch
well yeah that's very human for
something that's oh that's and here's
yeah here's where the aging stuff really
is right it's it's like these questions
of you build these systems that can
learn where you set the goal it figures
out the process it figures out the
details like in some ways that is the
most empowering thing is that we can
hope for right that humans specify the
goals don't have to spend their time
trying to figure out like okay exactly
have I program like you know if you're
at this angle with this digit then you
got to here and it lets us build systems
that can do things like think about
elderly care robots those gonna have to
be able to handle totally weird and
unfamiliar situations that no one could
possibly anticipate in program in we got
to be really trustworthy but they're
asking me so beneficial all right you
think about we've got this this
demographic time bomb that people talk
about you know we're all getting older
and how are supposed to take care of you
know 50 years and I think that this kind
of technology it gives us a path and so
I think there's something amazing there
but the thing it's really important
along the way is that the impacts that
we see that they help us be more human
rather than didn't feel threatened in
the so so one of the the open AI teams
there's a hundred of you now that's
right and and one of the teams is is
doing the
these reinforcement learning models for
dota 2 and then applying that to other
likely you said this robotic hand then
the other aspects of open AI as well
what this the security figuring out how
to handle things on a governance and a
geopolitical well so it deals about that
one and the other ones yep so you know
set against the technologists just to
focus on the technical problems so we
got this hard techno problem of can we
make systems that are smart at all
there's a second hard technical problem
of how do we make these actually do what
we wanted right and you know you will
have heard you know very sci-fi stuff
but I think that there's there's really
like three classes of risks that we're
worried about you know the first one is
systems that pursue misspecified goals a
little bit of a careful what you wish
for
scenario second class of risks are
systems that can be subverted by moshus
humans so that's if you can hack it to
an AI and make it do dad things you know
how do we make sure that that's not
possible but there's a third class of
risk which I think that people really
you know under pay attention to which is
it's possible we solve those problems we
build these trustworthy systems that do
what the operate at once but somehow the
resulting economy the resulting world is
not one that results in broad benefit to
human lives that somehow we have this
like these systems that are doing their
thing but it just kind of hasn't made
people's lives better and that one
that's very pernicious you don't want
that and so we have a safety team whose
job it is to think about parts of these
questions the technical parts of these
questions but we also have a policy team
whose job it is to think about not just
what you know how do we make sure it
pursues the goals that it's given this
question of well what should those goals
be like who has to say how do you make
sure that these systems that the world
that we build is representative right
that it really has you know broad buying
that it actually something that is able
to you know have government involved in
the right way that policymakers know
what's going on are able to put in the
right regulations and all of those
questions if it gets all the technical
stuff I've got to become the most
important questions to answer
you know the nuance that you just
explained safety and security risk
mitigation with
very interesting there's a lot of
different waste to get into and to make
sure that that were we're taking care of
all the different possibilities yeah and
then I mean this is just taking you
taking us - what does a beginning where
you just said that this is not a passing
fad or juses we're trying to enhance
humanity with this technology just like
we have with every single other with
other tech that we've built it also it
also does feel as though that there is a
potential to build a a an artificial
intelligence that does not have
consciousness like embedded in it
there's like this emerge this merge
scenario that is a very one that is very
popular that we merge the biological
beings with with the digital beings with
the with the digital play space that we
can that we're making right now what are
your thoughts around the transhumanist
movement and towards that digital space
and and whether than what you think is
potentially best I think it's really
hard to predict alright you think about
how can you even describe goober to
someone in 1900 yeah like how would you
do it yeah yeah yeah yeah how would you
explain airplanes to someone in 1500 yes
that wouldn't makes a little more sense
it's like we basically be the bird
that's right
that's right exactly right the mechanism
that makes sense and there's a lot of
concepts there but you know I think that
I think one thing that really
distinguishes information technologies
from a lot of the physical technologies
that we're used to is almost this degree
of like so hard to anticipate and
understand right like even the Internet
the Internet in some ways like you
described it to me I'd be like I don't
really know why I need one of those
right it's like okay the system that you
let's people connect like I don't know
we already have like the post like
what's what's the problem right and but
suddenly you get these capabilities and
they change the world in surprising ways
right you got a capability of you know I
can basically instantly psychically
communicate with anyone
on the planet called the text message
right you know I have to light something
with my you know fingers but like it's
not really any you know if I actually
literally had some some topically built
in I don't know be any better and so I
think that that the technology we've
built has already given us superpowers
in very very surprising ways different
and so I suspect that what's gonna
happen when we have even more powerful
technology it's just gonna be hard to
anticipate
I like how you give us a hefty dose of
humility that's that's needed it's just
there's so much conversation that's
happening about what's happening in 10
or 20 or 50 years and all this type of
stuff and yeah it's also equally
important to to aim to to extrapolate
what we do have today with this
cutting-edge neural network technology
and see where can be applied to maximize
human potential incrementally in love
the way in them so the medical field is
one of the big ones and preventative
preventive healthcare is also with the
medical imagery making better decisions
there what I want I'm curious to hear
what are your thoughts around the newest
protocols with decentralization
technologies being at play with
artificial intelligence because you yeah
and you because you guys also do have a
new aspect of open AI that's enabling
you to kind of gain it's called the LP
that's right yeah and so you know some
ways the so it can make you parts that
question you know what what is open ILP
and some ways open ILP is an
implementation detail of the open a
charter right so here this charter it
says here we're about we care about the
broad benefit we know we're gonna have
to raise huge amounts of resources but
we're gonna make sure that that mission
is served and it has a cap like you said
up that's right and the way that we
think about this cap right so so so you
know we kind of felt that you know so we
started as a nonprofit because we have
this mission it seemed like the most
obvious implementation of the mission
how are you both have a for-profit
company that's going to benefit everyone
it just wasn't it just felt almost
incompatible yeah and we spent really a
long time trying to figure out is there
a legal structure that gives us what we
need where our fiduciary duty primary
fiduciary duty
can be to the Charter rather than to
narrowly making money for investors you
know like I don't think that there's
anything wrong with returns for
investors I think that people would take
a risk should you know there should be
incentive for them to to do it but I
think that this technology that we're
talking about is just so powerful that
we've got to make sure that we have a
focus on making sure it goes well yes
and I don't think those things should
come into conflict but it's really
important to your priorities are clear
an inclusive stakeholder environment
that's right yeah and so we basically
goal structure out there it concluded it
wasn't quite the right one and so we
ended up custom writing rules for an LP
and to find what we call this count
profit it's the way that it works is
that investors are you know employees
have a similar similar you know sort of
like you know stock option granted to
them on have a capped return they put in
some money today they get a return but
if the company happens to generate more
value than that cap yeah that value
doesn't belong to any of the humans that
opening up that doesn't belong to the
AGI either it belongs to the nonprofit
organization that's very interesting and
so wrote your own code that's worth an
LP that yeah because there was no
available option to it before for that
before that's right yeah and and and so
and then from there you know and so it's
possible that the way that you know how
should a GI benefit everyone isn't in
the form of cheap or free AGI services
you know the AGI doctor may be right and
if that is then we have the flexibility
to do that or is it in the form of you
know something that somehow generates
capital and then you know you return
that to individuals and like actual
distributions also possible right but
the point is we're not locked in to any
of these outcomes but a thing we are
locked into that we are committed to is
the mission yeah that AGI will benefit
everyone yeah yeah and this is where the
decentralization component is is kind of
interesting is that where where do you
also balance out a centralized open AI a
hundred employees with a an open
protocol for other people from around
the world to how
yeah yeah so so I think that first of
all I think that there's a lot of really
interesting things going on in the
blockchain space and in particular
having these decentralized technologies
I'm actually on the board on of stellar
which is a non-profit crypto system
which as the mission of giving financial
access to the whole world yeah
and that was a project that I helped
launch in 2013-2014 I've been really
involved since and there's some really
interesting lessons from from what we've
seen it's doubler in fact when when we
initially launched so there's this coin
built into the network that we just gave
away to people for free right that's
part of the mission you want to give
everyone financial access give everyone
a stake in this network and there's a
literally the case that if you signed up
with a Facebook account you'd get this
stellar coin and it was worth about $10
at the time that we launched maybe $15
and so it's literally you have a
Facebook account you go you sign up you
got 10 15 dollars worth of coin and you
can actually literally sell it the day
that you got it right it's kind of this
amazing experiment in a lot of ways
where I've just like if you just let
anyone in the world sign up for this
thing like you know what happens and
that we saw this real exponential growth
that grew faster than anything I've ever
seen in terms of people claiming these
coins you know maybe not unsurprisingly
but I think it was very surprising was
we looked at where the signups were
coming from and there was this very
massive growing base of people in
countries like Vietnam or the
Philippines I'm sorry to dig in to
figure out how do people even hear about
what are they doing with stellar and we
started to find these forum posts where
it turns out that in a lot of these
countries there are these these I
there's these businesses that create
widget looking Facebook accounts and so
there's a lot of individuals who have a
lot of Facebook accounts that are
favored
yeah and at first I was furious right it
was we were trying to give financial
access to ever in the world these people
were stealing they were taking that away
from others but then you start to read
these forum posts and you see these
people would take would get their
stellar coins that would sell them and
they'd buy a goat for their village
interesting and you're like this is
amazing this is like almost a wealth
transfer from like you know these these
people these crypto speculators in the
first world to you know these these
people who just want to go to the
village like look at that impact that's
awesome right like it means for that to
happen but kind of cool that it did
but then you fast forward about three or
four years to the remember the height of
the crypto bubble of I guess I you know
early 2018 late 2017 we're just like
everything was skyrocketing is all very
high at that at that peak those stellar
that we gave to people ten fifteen
dollars sorry about $4,500 Wow
and something you realize that this
system resulted in a goat for this
village but resulted in these like cars
for the crypto speculators and the thing
that I think is really interesting I
don't think anyone think of anything
like you're just interesting to look at
the system I don't think that you know
it's about kind of that you know the
morality of it but it's it's really more
about the like there's this this this
tendency for capital to accumulate more
capital right the people who already had
the capital were able to speculate
therefore we're able to reap the
benefits of this platform succeeding and
so I think that the same is important to
look at with the future of AI egi right
I think it's not enough to solve a
technical problem of giving everyone
access at a technical level giving I'm
going to key that sort of thing yeah
doctors take advantage of that and the
thing about this dollar story so
definitely malevolent you got to watch
out for
right dollar stories but one's really
malevolent right you know there's the
people in being on whether these you
know Facebook accounts that they weren't
legit but I don't really view like that
the transactions that happened to be
illegitimate right now that the crypto
speculators almost like a fair
transaction right they did get the go
they took the risk you know all those
things but somehow that system was set
up in a way where it didn't result in
the Equality we were hoping for
and so with opening I think it's really
important and with AGI and these these
other technologies we're building to
learn from that and to think about how
do you set up the system not and you
know again like the technology is almost
a servant you know it's a servant to the
impact right it's a vehicle it's not
it's not the most important thing the
most important thing is what happens to
human lives and so that's the thing that
I really focus on I think that's a
really hard and really important problem
yeah and what is a skill that children
should learn
as we enter into the automation AI age I
mean so start with programming right
everyone should learn to program I think
that was everyone I think so I think so
I think it's I think it's a really
important way to understand how
technology works and how these software
systems that we all interact with how
they operate yeah yeah interesting okay
Wow
this has been super enlightening we have
a couple quick questions about though we
usually ask on a show to ask you yep all
right first question is are we alone in
the cosmos not not if we succeed at
building AG I didn't unpack that a
little more for us well I think I think
I think I actually Stan stands alone
yeah yeah I think that you know I've
real hopes for the what happens if we
succeed at building these really smart
technologies and I think that we can
build systems that will enhance human
lives but these systems will also be
different from us in in in real
meaningful ways and so I think that I
that there's there's there's something
something really amazing to discover
there so that AGI ends up helping us
discover other no I was referring more
more so that AGI is its own I think I
think there's there's there's a chance
in some ways it will be an other and in
some ways it will be like us and I think
we get to control that okay okay and
then are we in a simulation how hard to
predict I'm not sure what I would do
differently if we were in one versus not
yeah
you'd keep leveling up regardless yeah
and you know I think that it's you know
I like to separate out the kind of
concrete things that I can have
scientific intuitions about um I think
that for this question in some ways it
feels like 89 scientific question in the
same way that you know just like you
know is there a flying teapot out there
between Mars and Jupiter there might be
out of no way of disproving it but I'm
also not sure what changes might likely
here's one but that one that one is a
little bit more if you're just kind of
like throwing that like more of like
maybe a meaningless question out this
one is probably a more meaningful
question that can actually be probed
with science mm-hmm yeah potentially but
I think I would love I would love for
someone to try you know maybe in a
couple decades with Ag I will be able to
run the simulation of a big bang and
then see ourselves 13.8 billion years
later yes it's hard to have to rule out
anything yeah yeah you know last
question great what's the most beautiful
thing in the world my girlfriend this
has been so enlightening yeah
there's and we we're very grateful that
you've band you've band together some of
the the greatest minds out there to make
sure that we do AG ID right and that is
that that helps for our generation also
the older generations but especially the
younger generations to see your you know
your charter your principals your first
your values that you're building this
with and that helps them also want to be
driven towards similar first principles
and values and that's very powerful very
powerful thanks great thank you thanks
for coming on the show as we she ate it
we greatly appreciate you all for tuning
in
thank you very much we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below
about what was discussed you're going to
talk to more people about artificial
general intelligence what exactly goes
into this the power of neural network
everyone get programming those greg's
take away get programming understand
that this is a major part of our future
and that everyone should be at least
bayer basically fluent in it and who
shout out to ron vargas thank you very
much for producing and directing we love
you very much
everyone support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in and
all of the open a eyes links are below
support them simulation all our links
are below support us support the ones in
your community get them growing and
flourishing go and build the future
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon everyone
peace
you